but as people understand that inequality
fair-minded Americans are fair-minded
and they come to understand who we are
much more completely and are then open
to supporting not just legislative
endeavours for equality but cultural
frames which recast how we are
understood I think about separate from
coming out the other ways that we win
support and I have to tell you there are
particularly in 2010 the media and by
that I mean news and entertainment is
the most after coming out directly
people the most important the most
powerful way to help people understand
who we are and therefore for gay folks
gay lesbian bisexual transgender people
to achieve our equality and as impatient
as I might be as in there's a and
there's importance to that in patience
there we must be impatient to ask
America to treat us equally it's
important to understand that we going to
in our impatience win that by yelling
and a few congressmen we're going to win
or impatient our equality and use our
impatience best to our advantage by
taking it to the streets taking it to
the people you work with talking to the
people in our worlds and by supporting a
media that tells those stories fully and
fairly that if it's a news story about
gays in the military the stories of gain
gay men and women who are serving with
honor but are being hounded out of the
military which is wrong and people
understand that the stories of couples
that simply need to take care of one
another what traditional value can there
be in America one more conservative
value can there be than the institution
of marriage and what it entails taking
care of others and having the basic
rights to take care of one another
to protect not just your family but the
institution that we call America to
allow ourselves to reproduce that for
the next generation that's marriage and
that's something that I think Americans
when they understand it not through the
lens of somebody's
sort of radical conservative agenda to
raise money off of you know poor ladies
in Iowa right that they're sending these
mailers out where they characterize gay
folks as the devil but when they see the
reality of our lives you know we've kids
we get older we need to take care - we
have pensions that we need to pass on
there's no benefit to anybody else
there's no damage to anybody else's
marriage by giving the benefits the
responsibilities of marriage to our
families and we need those benefits to
take care of each other when people
understand that through stories that are
told responsibly through the Mediate new
stories or on television the television
show brothers and sisters where they
were hoping to marrying the prop 8
passes and then couldn't happen these
were responsible ways of communicating
important values and in many ways far
more persuasive far more impactful than
any amount of lobbying that we're going
to do on Capitol Hill to win our
equality shows like Glee and Modern
Family which give realistic sometimes
all too realistic portrayals of gay
families look you people are very very
important to helping America understand
particularly those Americans who don't
think they know anybody who's gay or who
knows somebody who's gay but those gay
friends and family members have never
bothered to sit them down and tell them
that they're second class and they
deserve to be treated fairly it's
amazing to me how many of my gay
brothers sisters my bisexual and
transgender brothers and sisters don't
tell their friends and family why they
deserve equality